Welcome to the very first design
competition
where once and for all
we will decide who is better.
The architects or the AIs.
Each team will be tested on their design
skills,
rendering skills,
and the ability to describe their work.
The winner will be unanimously decided
by our Discord
server, Archibeans.
Oh, hey, guys.
Welcome.
And to make sure human architects
can perform at their best,
HP provided the Z8 Fury G5
a powerful workstation equipped with 56
cores, 128 gigabytes of RAM 4 RTX
A6000 that will speed up
any human made process.
Thank you
HP for sponsoring this competition.
Much appreciated.
The competition's pull
from different phases
of the design process
and will lead to the design of a 280
square meter house on a hill.
Design a floor
plan for a 280 square meter house
on a sloped terrain
The site is approximately 3000 square
meters and approximately 20 degree angle.
The house must have three bedrooms
and a pool
and take advantage of the view
overlooking the hill.
So how many square feet was that?
Sorry. It's 280 square meters.
What was the angle of the slope?
20 degree slope.
As soon as they said plan,
I knew we had the advantage.
Our strategy was to simultaneously develop
three different ideas
since we knew the next challenge
was to create a compelling rendering.
We will pick an option
that leads to the most compelling form
a challenge within a challenge.
Option one The cantilevered
with the bedrooms on the bottom volume
and the kitchen and living spaces on top.
Both volumes cantilever
over the slope with minimal interruption
to the landscape.
The intersection of the two volumes create
a light filled double
storey atrium that connects the different
spaces of the house.
Option two The fan.
Like the name, suggests, this option
maximizes the width of the site.
Like a fan and creates
wide open views onto the hill.
We've got our bedrooms which are angled
towards the sun and living
and kitchen spaces, all in one story
with a pool right in the center.
Option three The Cascade.
This option follows the landscape.
Each volume gets a unique view
and the interior spaces overlook
onto each other, creating a connection
between different floors.
Each of the bedrooms get direct
exterior access with a pool jutting out
next to the living spaces.
That's actually pretty good.
All right.
We need to pick a plan.
Okay.
Well, I really like how your sits
in the topography and yours.
Look. Absolutely.
We need to pick one plan.
Guys, let's just pick
something that looks good in the renders.
what the hell?
Oh, wow.
That's a crack.
Yo can you try to model this?
Yeah. Hmm.
Yeah, right there.
It's kind of cool.
Challenge number two.
Develop The floor plans
into two compelling conceptual renderings
that tell the story of your building.
Take into consideration
the unique characteristics of the site.
The word compelling
is the key to this challenge.
All right, team.
So what's the game plan?
So someone needs to populate the site.
Someone need to do the building .
The pool.
That's going to be our money shot
No, they're not the pool.
Please, not the pool Not the pool.
All right, I'll take the landscape.
Okay. I'll take the building.
So, Trushit you take the pool.
Okay, That's really creepy.
The setting often makes
or breaks a render.
And because we didn't
have a huge amount of time
to spend in Photoshop,
nailing down the context.
Right in our rendering
software was essential.
Because of this,
we decided to use D5, which has
thousands of high quality models.
You can easily plop into your model.
You can see the changes in real time.
It's super intuitive and you can render
complex scenes without a problem.
So you can really speed up
the visualization process.
We laid down the grass
and combined different types of vegetation
that we felt worked in this landscape.
We wanted to bring focus
to the crevice at the center.
So the flanking volumes on
either sides should be quieter,
a bit more integrated with the site.
We decided to use wood siding
with the soffit and balcony in dark metal.
After playing around
with a bunch of different
material options,
we landed on concrete for the mass wall.
The pool is the money shot.
The entry experience should be exquisite.
With the refraction of the pool
showering you as you enter the house.
Equally important is the view
from the top, with the infinity
pool overlooking the hill.
Okay.
Are you guys ready?
All right, quick,
let's set up the views.
Nice, guys.
Look,
DAMN.
How about a video?
They can't do that, right?
Aare we allowed to do that?
Well, nobody said we can't.
Okay.
Video it is. What
about
snow?
Let's do snow.
AIs can't do video animations.
Right?
This is the last and final challenge.
Prepare a 150 word description
of your project.
Now, please wrap up all of your work
and package it for us to review.
The last hour of the deadline is typically
when everything starts to crash.
However, with the HP Z8 G5,
we can have multiple apps running
simultaneously since it came with 128
gigabytes of RAM that can even be expanded
up to two terabytes.
The case is awesome.
Two redundant power
supply for hot swappable M2
storage, super quiet cooling system
and plenty of connectivity.
The Z8 is the top of its line,
so it's a little bit expensive
and might be a little bit of an overkill
for what you need.
But HP also has other versions
of this workstation
which comes at a much lower price point.
Check out the link in the description
if you want to know more.
So over the last couple of days,
I've been asking our Discord community
to vote on these images.
I didn't give them any background
on the video
or the competition
or who made these images.
So the vote was pretty
much based on a gut feeling.
But I think it's a big enough pool
to get a sense for people's preferences.
So here's the results.
So the winner of all three challenges
the plan challenge,
the render challenge
and the text challenge was the AIs.
And I think we expected the images
to have a overwhelming majority
for the AIs,
but we were definitely surprised
by the text challenge.
You should also keep in mind that
if you look really closely at the plans
that MIDJOURNEY generated,
it doesn't actually make sense.
And that's because Mid Journey
is designed to produce pretty pictures.
And the way that I ask people to
vote is on a gut feeling.
So they weren't spending a lot of time
observing whether the plan was functional.
This was a really interesting process
because I think we're at a point now
where for certain tasks
AI can do them better than humans.
So the question is, should we be scared?
Is AI going to replace us?
I don't want to sugarcoat things.
Yes, I do think that AI will replace
a lot of jobs, including jobs
in the design and architecture field,
if not now, are very near in the future.
On top of what MidJourney can do,
there's a lot of other apps
that we didn't cover in this video,
like apps for generating massing studies
or apps for Generating Plan Iterations,
all of which we do pretty manually
right now.
This type of AI's called
ANI artificial narrow intelligence,
which is the type of AI that's designed
to solve specific tasks really well.
And they're only going to get
exponentially better every single year.
Maybe at some point
we're also going to have AI for doing
construction details or writing specs.
So I think the more specific
and siloed your job is,
the higher the chances are
that your job will be affected by AI.
I can't really get into the details of how
to situate yourself in this transition
right now, but I did make a video
on a book that does break this down.
I'll leave it right here.
But of course,
AI can't replace architects.
It can't take abstract constraints
and turn them
into functional, conceptual
and feasible designs.
It can't coordinate the work of other AIs
and it can't take liability for its work,
and it can't make clients
feel safe about the millions of dollars
in the investments.
There is another type of AI called
general AI, or strong AI,
which tries to replicate
the full human cognition
and we are pretty far away from that.
But once we get there,
we are pretty much screwed.
I think my biggest concern right now
is how A.I.
is going to influence the next generation
of architects and designers.
These tools generate
what feels like the final image,
and they put out
what feels like the final answer.
But it's skipping a lot of steps
to get to that stage.
Architecture is not really a pure art.
It's a creative response, but
it's a response to real life constraints.
And these responses
come out of a very non-linear process
of manipulating the form.
See how that changes the function...Or
maybe you can try to solve a problem
with materiality or light.
It's a constant back and forth
and back and forth,
all with the goal
of hopefully benefiting humanity.
Even the very beginning of a project
is a very labyrinthine process,
and you can actually see how I'm doing it
with one of my projects right here.
Overall, don't be afraid of
AI try to use it to your advantage
and constantly keep thinking
about how you can mix your existing skills
with AI to create
a whole new category for yourself.
We've been having a lot of fun with A.I.
in our office.
We've been using CHATGPT
for research, MidJourney
for generating thumbnails and storyboards.
By the way,
if you're interested in getting access
to all of this background material
that led to this video,
you can do that by becoming a Spoon
or a Producer of this channel.
You'll also get a step by step process
and a breakdown
for each of the design options
that we've created for this video.
I would love to hear what you guys think.
Do you think that
AI is going to replace us
and what do you think
the future is going to look like?
Let me know in the comments
if you enjoyed this video.
Give me thumbs up, and subscribe
if you want to see more videos
like this of that.
I'll see you guys in the next video.
Bum, bum, bum, bum,
bum, bum.
CHATGPT But you idiot.
You don’t know what dabbing is?
you are embarrassing
ass in front of the humans.